[Musique]
bonjour nikos aliagas bonjour merci
calloch camo comscore merci en tout cas
d'avoir accepté ce grand entretien pour
explorer votre identité européenne alors
on vous présente plus aux hommes de
télévision omniprésent depuis plus de
vingt ans maintenant journaliste
photographe homme curieux profondément
européen c'est en france que vous avez
grandi mais vos origines sont grecques
alors je trouve que vous avez une une
jolie formule pour parler de cette
double identité qui est la vôtre vous
dites je compte en français j'aime en
grec expliquez-nous la logique et
l'instinct l'héritage et l'apprentissage
oui ou non gm en grec parce que c'est la
langue maternelle
parce que je me suis retrouvé en france
2 par
l'exil entre guillemets de mes parents
des exilés économique des immigrés
arrivés en france dans les années 60
donc pour eux la la présence ici à paris
en tout cas était une présence passage
heures pour eux le leit motiv permanent
c'était le retour le retour d'ulysse
encore un mythe grec revenir au pays
gagner suffisamment dessous tout en
respectant le pays dans lequel ils
s'étaient installés pour revenir au pays
avec un diplôme pour le fils un peu plus
d'argent pour le père et continuer sa
vie là bas sauf qu'ils ne sont jamais à
partie mais l'exil a donné un sentiment
omniprésent dans ma famille que je porte
aussi aujourd'hui qui s'appelle le north
tous en grec s'adonnaient nostalgie d'un
mot homérique qu'on retrouve chez omer
c'est la souffrance du lys le retour
permanent le manque de quelque chose
donc j'ai eu un côté on va dire hérité
des facto dans mes gènes mettrait
invisible tout en étant très intégrée
dans un pays qui est devenu le mien qui
m'aimait comme un français de souche ça
me poser de questions qui va donner la
nationalité qui m'a donné le même accès
à l'éducation qui m'a donné la
possibilité de me construire de me
trouver cette double identité
aujourd'hui c'est une évidence mais ce
que ça l'a toujours été est ce que quand
vous aviez cet âge là cette cette double
identité était déjà une réalité où c'est
arrivé beaucoup plus tard est-ce qu'à
cette époque là vous étiez plus gracq
j'étais déjà dans une quête c'est sûr
trouver ta place
quand tu en grèce on t'appelle le
français quand tu es en france on
t'appelle aux grecs encore aujourd'hui
et finalement c'est l'europe qui me
sauve
c'est oui bien sûr je suis français je
suis grecque mais je repère d'abord la
grèce est entrée dans la communauté
européenne en 81
et finalement j'ai j'ai grandi dans les
années 80 comme un gamin
qui a petit à petit mille exilés la
nostalgie des parents de côté pour
transformer son envie de construire des
ponts en quelque chose de concret donc
trouver ma place trouver ma place avait
pas dire trouver une place c'est trouver
une identité et pour moi elle est
incontestablement elle est passée par
cette quête de l'europe quand je suis
jeune journaliste à l'époque et qu'on me
dit à rfi ou plus tard aux news tu vas
travailler justement sur les dossiers
grecs parce que tu connais bien le pays
et que je suis un journaliste français
c'est pour moi la première pierre de
cette construction de cette quête en
fait qui fait l'homme que je suis devenu
aujourd'hui ça continuera avec christine
bravo dans union libre ou vos jouets le
grec des services oui un peu par hasard
parce que christine venue me trouver au
départ pour lui donner des infos sur la
grèce moi j'étais journaliste on va dire
politique
je ne sais pas du tout divertissement et
j'arrive là-bas et donc je pense que je
vais l'aider un peu je vais écrire je
devenir le chef par la suite et du jour
au lendemain je me retrouve à faire le
grec et j'assume pas trop au début
d'ailleurs elle trouve que vous avez pas
effet l'accent oui justement samedi fait
bon y roulent moins ça roule moi je
voudrais bien vous dire tout ça je vous
parlais comme ma mère mon père je lui
dois beaucoup à christine parce qu'elle
m'a appris un métier que je ne
connaissais pas mais j'avais des doutes
en fait je vais voir mes parents je leur
dis mais est ce que j'ai fait tout ça
pour aller faire le grec de service dans
une émission de divertissement où chaque
passage
où je sortirai de mon chemin de
journaliste on va dire qu'elle me dit si
tu dois être aimé pour quelque chose
soit le pour ce que tu es et non pas
pour ce que tu crois être devenu très
intéressant donc une petite phrase comme
ça d'une petite dame d'un mètre quarante
neuf qui avait un fond philosophique et
finalement elle a eu raison parce que
j'ai appris un métier c'est grâce à
cette émission qu'on m'a remarqué et
même si j'en avais pas l'ambition elle
d'aller faire du divertissement ailleurs
j'ai accepté le pari ça m'amusait donc
oui oui la grèce est arrivé puis c'est
quand même un vrai quand on réfléchit y
avait pas de logique qu'un gars qui est
le grec de services jeux steam bravo se
retrouve sur la première chaîne d'europe
a présenté des divertissements en tant
que co animateur français
sur le papier non mais c'est ce passage
là qui est intéressant évidemment voilà
et ça m'a dérangé personne
j'ai pas reçu de courrier qui disait
mais que fait ce grec pourquoi ces
engrais qui présentait on n'a pas assez
de français
c'est très intéressant donc ma gratitude
envers la france quel pays kim a
structuré et qui m'a même je vais aller
plus loin aprilia à découvrir la grèce à
travers ses yeux je connaisse une grève
qui était une graisse affective poétique
la grèce de mon éducation familiale
dans la tradition orale dans les non
dits dans
l'instinct mais la france de par son
éducation et l'accès auquel j'ai eu
droit de parler grand helléniste comme
jacqueline de romilly qu'est devenue une
amie au chemin bas après à peut-être
reconsidérer ou décoder cet héritage
mais avec un esprit je dirais pas plus
cartésiens mais peut-être plus éclairés
donc cette autre demande j'ai essayé de
le construire comme une passerelle toute
ma vie un autre metteur que ce soit
entre le public et la télé que ce soit
en tant que journaliste animateur en
tant que grecques en tant que français
on en revient toujours à ça finalement
je n'étais qu'un passeur et ce parcours
là il fait de vous aujourd'hui un des
meilleurs ambassadeurs de l'europe parce
que c'est c'est évidemment ça qui est
intéressant c'est que vous êtes l'un et
l'autre et que au delà de l'un et
l'autre vous êtes aussi européens parce
que c'est possible et parce que vous
êtes fier d'être cette europe là aussi
expliqué nous
cette cherté juste devant nous est venue
votre européanité sur quoi elle se fonde
cette european it et sur quelles valeurs
allaient fondamentalement humaniste
elle met de côté la peur de l'autre
je me sens chez moi
un petit matin à valence sur la plage en
espagne je me sens chez moi l'après-midi
à stockholm
marché dans le capital et joue aux
échecs
et des fieux souhaité doit suédois que
je ne connais pas je me sens chez moi
turin à trois heures du matin en train
de manger une glace devant l'hôtel où
pavese et s'est suicidé à refaire le
monde avec de la poésie je me sens chez
moi en belgique en essayant de décrypter
le système des élections
belges jeunes journalistes alicja pour
moi un
micro mais je me sens chez moi
je me sens chez moi partout en général
et c'est servir à quoi ça le fait que
vous vous sentez autant chez voir ce que
ça à valence qu'à bruxelles parce que le
vieux continent a traversé les mêmes
épreuves nous avons eu lieu quasiment
tous les mêmes guerre les mêmes pandémie
depuis toujours le même héritage
on vient de deux cultures très puissante
qui sont rome et athènes avec des
influences
rap des influences juive des influences
indo-européenne bien avant mais c'est
ici que tout cela pris vie sur ce vieux
continent c'est une certaine idée de
l'europe c'est ça se vit au quotidien à
tel point qu'on oublie les privilèges
le privilège que d'être un citoyen
européen aujourd'hui
c'est pas seulement une histoire de
monnaie commune s'est pas seulement une
histoire de tout ça c'est du plus une
histoire de frontières abolis
même si certains voudraient les remettre
c'est une histoire de conscience
c'est une histoire de
de reconnaissance je dirais même je me
reconnais à travers le regard d'une mama
à cascais au portugal
qui promène son petit fils c'est
toujours la même histoire c'est cette
reconnaissance et cette gratitude qui
vous a poussé en 2015 à elle et à
athènes
pour le référendum pour encourager les
gens à voter oui parce que vous aviez
peur
et la perception à l'époque était
différente du côté des gracques
moi j'y suis allé pour d'autres raisons
et ceux qui étaient pour le nom
s'exprimer aussi pour d'autres raisons
ses excuses je parle jamais de politique
je ne m'engage pas publiquement parce
que je considère qu'on a pas à dire aux
gens pour qui tout a fauté c'est dire
que le secret de l'urne pour moi est un
secret
sacré mais à ce moment là mais à ce
moment là je le fais je le fais en
jantes jantes j'entreprends campagne
mais j'ai besoin de dire mes
compatriotes grecque que si vous sortez
de l'europe d'une façon ou d'une autre
ce sera le chaos ce sera un point de non
retour les anglais l'ont fait mais la
grèce n'est pas l'angleterre la grèce
géopolitiquement et dans une région
beaucoup plus instable
avec
des balkans qui sortent à peine la
torpeur
d'après guerre et du rideau de fer avec
un voisin oriental tantôt belliqueux
tantôt amical tout ça est très instable
donc je me suis dit dire non à l'europe
aujourd'hui
même si les grecs dans leur
mécontentement avait mille raisons de
l'être
mille raisons la vie était intenable
le cynisme de la troïka à son égard
étaient été minable je m'étais senti
piétiné par l'europe les grecs oui c'est
à dire qu'une appartenance européenne
cultural incontestable mais en même
temps un cynisme et puis le sentiment
d'être à rats de laboratoire on va vous
couvrez les vannes vous n'êtes genre
vous n'êtes pas digne et vous êtes des
voleurs et vous devez de l'argent on est
et on n'était plus dans l'europe là on
était dans un combat d'argentier et la
genèse grecs la classe moyenne grecque
qui s'effritaient quotidiennement la
jeunesse ne comprenait pas donc avait
une colère là c'est très dur d'aller
voir ses compatriotes en colère ma
propre famille mais propre cousin de le
dire mais je vous comprends mais il faut
rester en europe parce qu'il y avait eu
un raccourci le référendum était était à
la base contre les la politique
d'austérité de madame merkel qui était
devenu voilà
un ennemi entre guillemets
et moi je leur ai dit mais vous avez
raison c'est dur mais on ne peut pas
sortir l'europe a peut-être que je suis
un idéaliste un utopiste ou à trop
sentimental mais et mais si on sort de
l'europe s'il se passe quelque chose on
est foutu on doit rester une famille ça
s'engueule une famille ça se met ça met
tout sur la table ça arrive
c'est tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
dans une famille heureusement mais on
reste une famille parce que la grèce si
elle est profondément européenne
évidemment et puisque c'est l'agora
alors les grecs ont inventé la
démocratie mais on pourrait parler
pendant des heures
je ne suis pas ni philosophe du
spécialiste mais j'ai eu un peu quand
même sur la république dans la
république de platon la conception de la
démocratie elle n'était pas là même elle
était réservée aux citoyens déjà et pas
celui qu'ils n'avaient pas droit
au vote donc les femmes de voter pas
enfin de cette autre contexte autre
époque ne faisons pas les anachronismes
qui me met en rogne dont j'entends
aujourd'hui partout des économies est
bon il était dans un bain on est dans le
pays qui a inventé la démocratie et la
démocratie évolué on fait ce qu'on peut
tous la seule fois où je me suis exprimé
c'était pour parler de l'europe comme un
idéal et surtout comme à quelque chose
de précieux de fragile à garder
absolument parce que j'y crois c'est
plus fort que tout parce que quand par
exemple la grèce est menacée
très sérieusement il y a deux étaient de
ceux-là par
erdogan est le voisin turc avec qui on
veut vivre en paix
la france envoie tout de suite un
porte-avions et prend la parole et
défend un pays de l'union européenne
c'est ça la fraternité européenne c'est
de se dire aussi que demain on ne sait
pas de quoi est fait le l'avenir nous
vivons une guerre à 2h30 à 3h de
d'avions d'ici aujourd'hui avec
l'ukraine on doit être plus solidaires
que jamais ce qui me frappe quand je
vous entends c'est que
l'europe on sent que vous l'avez dans
les tripes or pour beaucoup de gens
autour de nous c'est europe c'est une
institution c'est quelque chose de très
théorique encore six as we pour donner
encore alors que vous c'est quelque
chose que vous ressentez profondément
quelque chose qui vous est fait sortir
de vos règles habituelles comme vous
l'avez expliqué où vous vous êtes
exposés en sachant que ça allez vous
attirer pas mal de problèmes
parce que c'est là en fait dans le
ventre et parce que j'y crois
qu'est ce qu'on ferait si on avait que
des ennemis autour de nous ferait quoi
on a vécu comme ça pendant des siècles
on s'est entretué pendant des siècles
mal europe m'a permis non seulement de
trouver un chemin travail
une identité mais de pouvoir me sentir
sans complexe et d'en apprendre sur
l'autre partout est ce que si on n'aime
pas
suffisamment l'europe c'est parce qu'on
parle pas assez de culture européenne
d'après vos jeux j'en suis persuadé je
pense que c'est la question essentielle
la plus importante à force de parler que
d'argent autour de l'europe et de
politique alors que l'europe c'est une
affaire de du quotidien c'est une
affaire dont je voulais dit tout à
l'heure et j'en suis persuadée de
reconnaissance de culture
essayer de voir
ce qui nous unit et quand bien même on
n'est pas d'accord ce qui ne complète
dans la culture à travers les arts à
travers la littérature l'histoire mais
moi c'est la culture qui m'a fait même
si aujourd'hui je présente des émissions
divertissement mais c'est cet accès à la
culture qui m'a permis de comprendre ce
que je voulais
cette europe j'y crois pas que pour des
raisons on va dire pratique des raisons
institutionnelles ou des raisons
politiques mais pour des raisons d'abord
affective europe et y faut pas l'oublier
elle a été enlevée par zeus tout à
l'heure vous parlez d'une europe ouverte
cette europe que vous aimez cette fine
europe ouverte sur l'extérieur
j'aimerais vous soumettre une photo dans
l'écran celle ci ne dure à son duo ces
photos parce que tout autour de l'europe
et en grèce notamment on voit beaucoup
ces images
qu'est ce que ça vous évoque comme ça
ça me fend le coeur
je ne sais pas d'où été prise cette
photo grâce à lesbos mais ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que quand les premiers
les premières personnes sont arrivées je
veux pas dire les migrants elle veut
rien dire n'est pas un migrant on est un
père je vois des pères ou des mères des
enfants sur une femme qui tient un petit
ceux là sont arrivés je ne sais pas où
ils sont aujourd'hui
on ne sait pas pourquoi ils sont arrivés
on ne sait pas ce que le sort de la
ville leur a réservé mais quand ça s'est
passé les premiers à plonger c'était les
pêcheurs en pleine crise qui n'avait
rien pour sauver une âme et ces hommes
ces femmes ces enfants et nous
questionnent sur les valeurs de l'europe
sur nos valeurs et de qui nous sommes
est ce qu'on est capable de leur donner
vous êtes inquiet vous par la montée des
populismes en europe justement et par
rapport aux réactions de peur et de
rejet ils ont toujours existé sauf qu'on
les autant un peu plus mon père est avec
une valise il n'était pas sur un bateau
mais il est arrivé à la gare de lyon
avec une valise et la dormait sur un
banc la première nuit parce qu'ils
savaient pas où dormir parce que
l'adresse de son copain enfin gars
étaient morts failli trouver ça n'a pas
empêché de faire son chemin et d'aimer
la france de respecter le pays de de
rendre au pays d'accueil ce qui lui
avait donné ce qu'il a donné ensuite à
sa famille donc la meilleure réponse
c'est parler avec épreuves avec des
actes
les cassandres encore un concept inventé
par mes amis grecs ont un rôle
particulier à jouer
mais les sages ont le rôle de la fin
celui qui clôt le débat et je crois
encore à la sagesse et j'espère
que
l'huile sur le feu
ne fera pas plus de dégâts d'eau ravages
quand vous êtes inquiet justement
préoccupé par ce que vous observez
autour de vous c'est dans la philosophie
grecque surtout que vous trouvez des
enseignements de la matière à réflexion
à mettre en perspective
oui peut-être aussi dans la grande photo
jeu
zoom out
dans le champ large pouvoir tous les
paramètres il faut pas se perdre dans le
détail du zoom cdd époque remplit l'une
remplace l'autre il restera rien du
bruit
rien
j'aimerais vous soumettre un petit
questionnaire européen si l'europe
devait être incarné par une personnalité
nikos aliagas tout à l'heure vous
mentionniez hugo victor hugo ce serait
celui
parce qu'il a été voilà un poète on
parlait de la culture
ils étaient tous il faisait de la
politique aussi il a tout vécu
on l'a chassé de france il est revenu
on l'a critiqué en la dic si à la fin on
l'a
on la pente est honni zay hugo pour moi
reste
un européen un visionnaire avant l'heure
c'est le premier à avoir parlé des états
unis d'europe il a eu très tôt une
vision de l'europe oui s'adresse ou
russes aux anglais et ils d'image où on
fera partie de la même famille comme les
normands où toutes les provinces
françaises qui étaient autonomes se son
voile a rallié à la france pour créer un
concept d'unité nationale et hugo était
aussi un immense filet laine et au dix
neuvième quand la grèce justement
cherchent à se libérer du joug de
l'empiré ottoman
les grandes puissances de l'époque joule
aussi leur intérêt parce qu'elles ont
des intérêts économiques depuis quatre
siècles depuis la fin de de byzance et
de la chute de constantinople donc ce
sont ces intellectuels comme hugo
chateaubriand byron 1 en angleterre et
défilé les allemands aussi et d'autres
qui vont insuffler auprès des
occidentaux de l'époque
le devoir et le droit des grecs à à
s'autodéterminer avoir leur pays et donc
j'ai une admiration pour lui il a écrit
l'enfant grec et surtout il à hilla il
s'est toujours adressé dans la grande
photo dont on parlait tout à l'heure
s'adresser aux gens avec la sagesse on
en revient au vieux sage surtout la fin
de sa vie est hors ue go
respect monsieur si l'europe était un
paysage ni graisse
je pense à titre totalement subjectif il
serait la côte méditerranéenne
d'olivier de cigales de bleu
chaleur un peu comme ça
c'est ça notre marais nostrum notre mère
nous la méditerranée qu'est-ce que je
laime est-ce que je laime si l'europe
était un tableau
je restais dans le 19e tout change un
tableau dont a parlé dicte origo un
tableau de delacroix
à des lacroix qui avait la grèce qui a
peint la grèce sur les ruines de
missolonghi
je viens de missolonghi mes parents
viennent de missolonghi qui est une
ville qui fut rasé
justement par les troupes de l'empiré
ottoman
1826 au terme de plusieurs années de
siège de plusieurs sièges mais sont
jamais rendus comme à sarajevo
elle est terrible cette image parce
qu'en fait nous célébrons
un deuil
ce jour là
toute la population va être massacrés
quelques survivants seront vendus sur le
marché des esclaves en egypte ou en
afrique
et les hommes seront décapités on fera
des colliers de leurs oreilles pour les
envoyer à la porte sublime
les femmes et les vieillards se réfugier
dans des églises attendant que
la sasion arrive mettant le feu aux
poudres pour
pour mourir avec eux
et pourquoi ces drames parce qu'il lui
sera bien l'europe parce que
c'est à ce moment là que l'europe qui
n'a rien fait pour mission longue il
réalise
au delà de la honte et de la culpabilité
réalise là son manquement
à nos valeurs qui font on appartient à
la même culture et en même temps ce sont
quelques semaines plus tard quand on a
appris la chute de missolonghi les
étudiants
histoire d'art et de philosophie qui
vont manifester a évolué
ce sont les auteurs comme chateaubriand
et d'autres comme hugon la cité tout à
l'heure qui vont
inspiré de la population en disant ce
sont nos frères ce sont nos frères
européens on vit en ce moment la même
chose est-ce qu'on voit les abandonner
et puis la grèce se libérera quelques
années plus tard deviendra effectivement
grâce notamment à l'appui de la france
un état avec plein d'autres problèmes
des guerres civiles mais bon si ça sera
jamais facile et de la croix peint cette
femme qui symbolise la grèce qui a tout
perdu et qui sera rassemblement tués
dont on ne connaît pas l'avenir
et ce tableau qui existent et qui a été
présentée souvent louvre mais qui
existent ou au musée des beaux-arts à
bordeaux
borges de cheryl est immense il est
magnifique
j'ai eu la chance d'exposer mes photos
des habitants de missolonghi
d'aujourd'hui dans le costume du 19e
siècle
en face de lui et je me sentais petit
petites choses en même temps c'était ma
façon dans une étrange communion et
synchronicité de remercier ce peintre
que j'admire et qui fut aussi pour mon
père
une petite reproduction dans son
portefeuille quand il est arrivé à paris
et quand on lui demandait vous venez
d'où disait de grèce mais 12°
cimenterait ça je peux pas l'oublier
si l'europe était en hymne nikos
si on les met de la joie c'est sympa
mais bon je m'étais fans c'est pas mal
mais si on vous demandait une alternance
d'oeuvre
bien côté je fais pas un peu un peu
cucul la praline
pardonnez moi ce jeu est attirée les
foudres des mélomanes mais moi je dirais
ravel
le boléro de ravel
quelque chose de cinématographique avant
l'heure ravel disait que c'était son
jeu il disait j'ai fait un chef d'oeuvre
dans laquelle il ya pas de musique pour
le laisser en dessous remonter un peu
c'est une boucle en fait il ya certes
mais c'est une boucle qui mentent et
c'est une boucle où les instruments ou
les instruments se répondent
ils jouent tous la même note ou les
mêmes notes mais ils ne se ressemblent
pas
[Musique]
puis c'est une énergie phénoménale sa
lancée d'un
raconte tous notre histoire la même
histoire on se ressemblent pas et on va
tous dans la même direction et on monte
on monte on monte à l'avant on met tout
sur la table c'est le bordel absolue
elle recommence
c'est la fascination de ravel pour
l'espagne qui fait ce volet web
mais c'est la première fois que j'ai
entendu le boléro je lai je les ai vus
au cinéma
je pense
les uns les autres claude lelouch avec
cette danse magnifique ce danseur
magnifique sur le parvis du trocadéro et
j'ai une émotion gamin tellement
puissante
parce que précisément lellouche arrive à
transfigurer un morceau qui n'est pas de
son époque en quelque chose d'universel
et la construction de cette musique
même s'il n'ya pas de voice n'est pas de
voix dedans c'est la plus belle voix de
l'ordre pour moi j'aurais adoré un jour
je veux pas référendum votées changeront
leur adrénaline l'hymne à la joie sympa
ça fait son temps sorties blu
ray c'est avec ça qu'on va conclure
c'est une belle conclusion mercian
écossais vegas pour ces grands
entretiens sur vous de m'avoir
accueillie c'était un plaisir pour moi
aussi
[Musique]